die Menschen der Sahelzone am Südrand
der Sahara sind ständig von Hungersnöten
bedroht das liegt an den häufigen Dürren
und dem unfruchtbaren Böden denn über
Jahrzehnte wurden nach europäischen
Vorbild die Bäume auf den Eckern gefällt
was zur Bodenerosion und zur Ausbreitung
der Sahara in den Sahel geführt hat das
great green wall-projekt sollte mit
einem 15 km breiten Waldstreifen durch
den Sahel die Ausbreitung der Wüste
aufhalten aber der ursprüngliche Plan
funktioniert ja leider nicht teil 2 die
falschen Bäume gepflanzt wurden teils
wegen schlechter Organisation und teils
auch sozialen Gründen aber das Projekt
hat sich jetzt neu angepasst und
konzentriert sich nun auf die
Wiederherstellung der Bodenfruchtbarkeit
in größeren Gebieten und die
Einbeziehung der lokalen Bevölkerung vor
allem die politische Instabilität der
Region und finanzielle Engpässe sind
aber weiterhin große Probleme aber das
Projekt macht Fortschritte und
unterstreicht die Notwendigkeit den
Klimawandel und den Verlust der
biologischen Vielfalt zu bekämpfen denn